he said it was in the paper the other
day an estimate that one out of four
dollars
in the banking community in miami uh was
drug money now you have that kind of
money and tolerance of the thing at the
top the white house involved
oliver north getting memos back and
forth with robert owens saying these
people were working are smuggling drugs
knowing about it giving protection ed
meese giving protection fending off
investigations
george bush through greg rodriguez and
the others actually running flying the
drugs if they were interested in and if
they were really interested in purging
our society from drugs
you could do it pretty quickly if you
went after the bankers so they couldn't
profit from it anymore and then you
impeached bush and jayleem and a bunch
of other people at that level
and and just the information that they
haven't and and started locking people
up at that level then start down and you
could dry this thing up or the irony as
i note in my vietnam book where i i
saw a pipeline for drugs going through
my province i tried to report it to my
boss
and he just put me off he said come on
they've been trying to stick us with
that for years you know the drug
smuggling and i said no no this is
someone using a ci jeep and we can nail
him
and he said you're not a cop
the regular media focus on the drug
cartels in colombia and elsewhere around
the world
but it's a lot bigger people than that
who are involved in controlling it
we talk about this right now with john
stockwell
on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in our last previous program former cia
official john stockwell analyzed the
1988 elections
one of the subjects was the relationship
of george bush with the international
narcotics trafficking
in this program
we're going to assess the total
framework and operation of the narcotics
trafficking and we also will see how the
u.s high officials have been involved
for quite some time
we start out by looking at george bush's
office where donald gregg is a key
figure
greg is a former c.i.a official
and then when bush became vice president
his old cia buddy donald gregg appeared
again in the white house as one of
bush's chief political
operatives then once the contra had
their money shut off from congress with
the bolan amendment they started to go
to all sorts of sources to get illegal
money for arms including a drug ring and
some of the arms drug ring people had
connections with donald gray who was
bush's old cia
operative and now his
washington chief chief advisor on
terrorism and
cia a career ci officer
detached the vice president's office to
advise him on security matters national
security affairs did you know him when
you were in the cia i didn't know him
but he was in the category of people
like in the navy that you know by
service reputation he was the chief of
base of military region 3 in vietnam
just before i got there
and and so the people that i worked with
were coming out from under
his shadow as a matter of fact they
rather liked him
especially compared to the nerd who
replaced him and so they were all
talking back to well don greg was
fearing downgrade was this now with don
greg in vietnam was also a man named
felix rodriguez
and this is where you get into
the deeper
ci linkage now i have not been able to
clarify
if rodriguez who had been part of the
cuban exile community the operation
mongoose destabilization of cuba
had become a ci staff officer which i
don't think would be possible according
to the rules unless they made some kind
of an exception he would have been a
career con a contract officer
but we see bush makes it into the the
vice presidency and greg is on his staff
clearly a connection that he brought in
from his cia day someone he had met
and had confidence in
or god knows a deep relationship with
the big question marks about how when we
know bush is plugged in by one or two
steps uh to the drug mafia as we said
before
uh noriega bragging that he's got bush
by the balls this is pretty heavy uh
uh indictment now how far does that date
back was it an innocent from the cia
director doing his job in 76 or did he
get somehow entrapped and involved back
then we don't know but still
greg shows up
in the vice president's office and then
felix rodriguez shows up
as part of the contra program trying to
straighten it out trying to manage it
working in illupongo and el salvador
wearing salvadorian air force uniform
for cover and testifying for the iran
contract committees
but they didn't ask the deep questions
about drug smuggling and the connection
now
the way this all began to break was the
huss infuse
when he was captured he had the vice
president's phone number uh on him and
then that leads to the well where were
you flying out of and while he was
flying out of ilopongo
and then the journalists start going and
checking the phone records in in el
salvador which were public information
and finding these innumerable calls up
to the vice president's office to donald
dragon to donald greg and from felix
rodriguez
calling you know continuously obviously
coordinating intimate details
of an illegal operation when the bullen
you know amendment had shut down u.s
government involvement in this thing and
rodriguez was doing what was he in
rodriguez was he was in
the ilopongo air force base in el
salvador
in charge of the air wing the airy
supply bringing supplies to the contrast
bringing supplies to the contrast
illegally obtained supplies to the
conscious although apparently he was
there before the bullet amendment was
passed so he's functioning
legally and bringing supplies to the
contras then
and these phone calls and then trips by
rodriguez up to washington to report to
greg
and then pressing further the
journalists found that that in the vice
president's log there were three entries
of times where where he had met with
felix rodriguez
bush himself now
greg when he was questioned about you
know all this
by the congressional committee said that
he had not had any reason to brief the
vice president on anything that
rodriguez was doing
and uh obviously plausible denial
protect the boss clearly obviously bush
knew what was going on and and then the
word the official word bush refused to
be questioned but the word was put out
that they had not talked about any
national security matters or any contra
activities
which of course is utterly implausible
denial
then you take the linkage a step further
felix uh arranging according to the
testimony of millian rodriguez who was
laundering money for the medellin large
sums of money the columbia drug card
that's right and he testified that that
they had put the hit on him and he had
arranged to have a 10 million dollar
donation given to the contras during the
bullet hiatus they went around and said
look the congress has shut off the money
if you want you know actually you gotta
you gotta cough up a little bit
and this was uh
i would guess chicken feed in terms of
the amount of drugs that were flying
from the
see this is a dream situation for the
drug smugglers
they're under constant pressure to find
ways to get the you know their material
their product up into the states to sell
it and every mule every kind of ruse
scheme device they can and then here
dropped out of the sky
you know a gift from the white house
is a contra program where you have
planes flying daily between central
america
and
air national guard bases and air force
bases in the states but cia getting
special passes so that everybody
involved plane lands that pilot has
special pass the guards don't stop him
that's national security the dea picks
up on some cocaine out here in town and
tracks it back
to coming off of homestead air force
base
and he pursues he gets a phone call
saying hey you know that's national
security you know stop following that
pilot around they approach the pilots to
try to lean on them a little bit and the
pilot show him a phone number and it's
oliver north's phone number in the white
house
and he you know got caught national
security called the national security
council and and so the dea backs off the
fbi agents are trying to do their job
back off and you have this at several
key
air national guard and air force bases
across florida and alabama and louisiana
and texas
and this is a dream for the drug mafia
in addition to which
by definition ci operations intelligence
operations are immoral that's the way
they describe that's what it says in the
book
if if i debate them today which i do
they say wait a minute you know don't
bring morality into this this is an
admiral world
we in the intelligence business deal
in
what you're saying right there you can't
judge people for smuggling drugs because
it's immoral
illegal well they break the law all the
time it's illegal to run secret wars
it's illegal to bribe spies to give
information it's all illegal and immoral
so you cannot go to the boss and say
we can't fly these planes because
there's some drugs involved and that's
wrong because what's wrong wrong means
moral and immoral and you're not
permitted to say that
you're only permitted to say well the
arms are flying and you know well if
some drugs are coming back
on the return flights that's the dea's
problem when the dea tries to get
involved they call the boss and the boss
says that's national security when the
attorney in florida tries to prosecute
then ed me says no prosecution this is
national security
on the other hand you see
instances or read about instances where
the dea
drug enforcement administration
and the cia seem to be working
side by side and the dea cooperating
with them not just in a very complex
world oh yes oh yes absolutely by no
means are all of the dea
officers innocently trying to do their
jobs while the ci is corrupt for the
first thing the dea was formed
uh by by an amoebic separation from the
cia
it was staffed essentially with ci
office at the outset yeah
my boss in vietnam went back to be a
deputy uh in charge of the dea oh well
and under that oh yeah that matters
because they're just part of the old boy
network yeah the intelligence network
now
that's ironic because if the cia was
running drugs in vietnam laos and
elsewhere some of the same people that
were running the drugs then go to be the
enforcement agency against drugs coming
in the u.s or the irony as i note in my
vietnam book where
i saw a pipeline for drugs going through
my province i tried to report it to my
boss
and he just put me off he said come on
they've been trying to stick us with
that for years you know the drug
smuggling and i said no no this is
someone using a cia jeep and we can nail
him
and he said you're not a cop
you know you don't have the powers of
arrest you don't have the powers to
investigate things like that you're not
supposed to be carrying weapons that's
the dea's job with the south vietnamese
police you know leave it up to them
shouldn't we go to and talk to them
about it no we should stay out of it and
so this man a few months later goes back
to the states to become vice director of
of the dea the newly formed dea and i
actually write in my book that i hope he
had a little bit of a change of heart
and policy towards drugs when he got
into that field but
the thing that that you have to
understand is it's it's a it's a we try
to sort it out here and in a few minutes
on the air
give a sense of what's happening but
you're talking about a very complex with
lots of subtleties just because some
professors at a university smoke pot
doesn't mean that everybody at the
university smokes pot
and just because some people you know at
a university experiment with
with animals improperly or sometimes
human beings improperly doesn't mean
that everybody at the university is is
corrupt and evil
and and the same thing you have dea
officers who risk their lives to try to
stop the drug drug trade they really do
and and then you have
ultra-complex situations where someone
is recruited into the dea
put in to penetrate a drug ring
to survive breaks the law
helps smuggle drugs that's breaking the
law gets involved in killing because
that's the penetration and that's what
they're doing
to the point where they lose contact
with right and wrong and and then to the
point where and there's no documentation
see this is where it becomes so
insidious is they recruit you they put
you out under deep cover all the files
you know that prove who you were in the
documentation they keep in their safes
in the building at a certain point you
become expendable uh they have all the
proof that you were in fact a dea
officer you have none zero nothing with
which so they can cut you off and
prosecute you for being a member of the
drug mafia at any time they want and so
you get into corruption mounting on
corruption with layers and layers and
layers
of complexities and liabilities and
people gone sour and people blackmailed
and people corrupted and people
corrupting each other
the classic i mean it surfaces every now
and then one of the most fascinating
ones i caught on tv was the
one of the dea chiefs in panama
doing an interview and and looking at
the cameras utterly straight face and
saying that it was it was total
balderdash that that noriega never had
anything to do with any drug smuggling
in his entire life
this clearly was a man who was bought
and paid for you couldn't possibly say
that about noriega or very many other
people
in in power in in central america
especially noriega but here was our dea
guy in panama assuring the cameras that
noriega was squeaky clean this points to
the hypocrisy and the whole reagan
administration foreign policy where the
war on drugs is one of the top domestic
goals supposedly headed by george bush
the reagan administration headed by
george bush publicized by nancy and ron
don't you know just say no the drugs are
the major evil of our society and we
need a drug-free america they have tests
of employees government employees and
others to see what their drug intake
level is etc and then at the same time
the foreign policy of the reagan
administration is totally involved with
the biggest drug dealers in the world in
central america noriega the honduran
military
the haitian military the contra
operation these are the groups that have
been bringing all the drugs into the
united states and these are the reagan
administration's closest allies in
addition the cia the dea and these drug
enforcement agencies are also involved
with the smugglers at least on some
levels and in some cases this is where
you get into the the mockery of
of some of of of the system
take people uh conservative thoughtful
responsible moral people like my father
and he hears about a drug testing
program
and his reaction is yes i don't that's a
good idea if they test everyone you'll
find the ones who are using drugs and
you'll screen them out because god knows
he he he you know is never and would
never and nobody that he relates to ever
would and now
and and and you can carry that argument
to a certain distance if it were not for
this corruption that you're referring to
at the top
when you have the top
this deeply involved
in the drug smuggling and providing
airplanes for the drug smugglers when
you have our big bankers laundering the
money and bringing it back into the
system i was on a radio show in miami
and i was referring to this
yeah and i was referring to this uh
problem
to the money and this guy said
my host he said he said it was in the
paper the other day an estimate that one
out of four dollars
in the banking community in miami
was drug money now you have that kind of
money and tolerance of the thing at the
top the white house involved
oliver north getting memos back and
forth with robert owens saying these
people were working are smuggling drugs
knowing about it giving protection ed
meese giving protection fending off
investigations
george bush through greg rodriguez and
the others actually running flying the
drugs
now this makes an utter
mockery of their
claim of a war against drugs so then you
come back
and look at the drug testing clearly
they're not
interested in cleaning drugs out of the
society
so why are they trying to get into the
testing and that's where you become very
suspicious because that's a tremendously
effective tool for population control
as one and the
destruction of civil liberties
exactly see they're not if they were
interested in and if they were really
interested in purging our society from
drugs
you could do it pretty quickly if you
went after the bankers so they couldn't
profit from it anymore and then you
impeached bush and jay lehman a bunch of
other people at that level and and just
the information that they haven't and
and started locking people up at that
level then start down and you could dry
this thing up
then god knows at some point but they're
not going to do that that's the big
bucks that's the big money they're going
to do that so you know why do they want
to test on drugs well like you say
control violation of the so they don't
like civil liberties give them more
control over the people the latest big
push and we narrowly dodged a bullet
thank god even the pentagon got scared
of this one
uh was trying to push the army
now this is the the ultra-conservatives
uh dream fantasy is to get the army out
there with the power to arrest
soldiers driving up and down the streets
and jeeps that can take you and me and
anyone else and hold them off in the
drug war
now this when the congress you know
voted on it oh yes do it great charge
and carlucci even god knows not a saint
by my standards in my own personal
opinion
he went on the air and said
my boys aren't trained we can't handle
that one but that would be a big step
towards the kind of fascism that ronald
reagan his revolution the pat buchanans
the others were advocating
uh earlier at the height of his
presidency john can we go back and get
some history here we've been talking a
lot in a lot of programs and a lot of
news stories over the past several
months and years about the cia and drugs
there have been one or two books written
about it
can you give us uh how far does this go
back
it it goes back to world war ii it goes
back before world war ii it goes way
back in history it goes back into a time
when drugs were tolerated in this
society and they were not illegal which
is not all that far
back at the turn of the century
in saigon french had made vietnam a
profitable colony by having the the
heroin processing plants
in saigon and then they actually had
quotas villages had to buy and use x
amount of opium
and that was a way to ensure that the
french colonial corporations made money
from the vietnamese
bring it you know up to the 40s bring it
in well there were opium wars too where
the british forced it on the chinese
absolutely forced them to buy by opium
when the china the chinese were trying
to say no exact british brought their
guns in for example as a means of social
control that also is another reason why
drugs are tolerated in the u.s and other
capitalist countries because it is a
form of social control people are stoned
out on drugs addicted to drugs obsessed
with drugs
they're going to
not be
social uh rebels exactly between between
commercial television and lots of crack
you can take a lot of the guts out of
the society without question well what
happened then is pre-work well what we
have documented is this this kunmin unit
the oss unit in kunmin china uh uh
paying its bills with heroin
at a time when dollars were not
acceptable in that part of the world
we have and and then that growing with
the relations with the drug smugglers
and in a society where it was legal and
and and you know getting right into it
on on the other side you have the uss or
army intelligence getting lucky luciano
out of prison and setting him up through
italy to re reactivate
uh the mafia
to run operations against the germans
justified by the horrors of hitler's you
know of the war
and then funded and and the
infrastructure developed and then after
the war these people of course they're
blowing and going in the chaos and
confusion after the war
resulting very quickly uh in the french
connection bringing the heroin through
france into the united states
on back to southeast asia
you have the ci's massive uh
destabilization of communist china
which went on for a decade and a half
with the [ __ ] men the generals the
kumentang the generals profiting the
chinese as we call them with the civil
air transport air america airplanes
flying it and then when we got into the
vietnamese uh picture but the french
were flying
arms into the the pathet lao to the the
lotions to the metal and fly into the
molten yards in vietnam and flying out
with with the heroine fighting the
passenger and this
led to the and little airstrips they
built little airplanes and and when the
french lost the battle of jim yen
the us stepped in
and took over the entire operation
and there was only a slight interruption
in the flight you know the plane's
landing you see eye planes going right
in there start flying exactly where the
french had been flying there was a
little bit of friction which has been
documented between
uh the cia's station chief
lansdale and then three-fingered luke
conan after him and the sicilian mafia
who had been synonymous with the french
intelligence
flying this this the heroin the opium
as they sorted out you know who would
control it at what point because the cia
did not really get involved in it in the
sense of taking over of controlling it
they were flying in arms and their
allies were there
their clients like the quantras were
flying back out with the heroin so it
was a question of at what point was it
turned back over to the international
drug machine so what was going on there
was that there were communist forces in
laos and vietnam there were other
non-communist forces that were fighting
them and the us allied themselves with
the non-communist forces
and brought arms to them that were paid
for in part at least by drugs or at
least they allowed their non-communist
allies to smuggle drugs in their planes
as part of the alliance they were
developing the arms were paid for with
u.s tax dollars right but what happens
is and and it gets fascinating we have
in our associate we had in our
association uh a strong member ralph
mcgee well i served up country in
vietnam he served a couple of tours in
vietnam a couple of tours in laos right
up in a puppy growing uh part of the
world
where he would be walking out with these
people look at this or do that and
they'd have the heroin right with them
and you know climb in the jeep and drive
off and well did you challenge them
about hell no they'd shoot me
and then you get on the plane and
they're sitting there with two suitcases
well the ci pilot's position is that
he's not a cop in that country he does
not have the power to arrest
he can say get off my plane but if he
does that he'll just never fly again and
also he'll lose his contacts and his
allies that he's working with for his
own goals
he if he writes it up to his boss and
say general so-and-so was on my plane
i'm sure he had heroin the boss will say
how do you know well i forced him to
open the suitcase well you can't do that
with our allies see so he loses his job
and someone else flies the plane well
this makes it sound like they're kind of
helpless uh people in in kind of
bystanders but on the other hand
there was a nugent hand bank in
australia
which was cia dominated and controlled
which was heavily involved in financing
and laundering money of this dope
traffic that you were talking about in
southeast asia
well understand the gray the areas of
gray now this does not don't
misunderstand my comments i uh i hope
i'm sure i would never have flown a
plane knowing that there was heroin on
it when i found heroin going through my
province i tried to report it
however interestingly enough i didn't
quit my job
i did shut off that jeep so it couldn't
run anymore but you know i didn't quit
my job nor did ralph mcgehee you know
working in the middle of the poppy
growing world quit because of the the
certainty that heroin was being flown on
the planes
you just put blinders on
and what's going on it's gone on for
centuries that's the way asia is my job
is you know i've got my briefcase and my
reports here and i don't have any legal
authority to do anything about changing
the rest of the world in the drug
problems so i'm going to go down and
give the boss these reports i've been
working on for two weeks the new good
hand bank thing again the complexities
of these situations it was started by
two former cia officers clearly
at the intention of the cia
very sloppy operation lots of
fraud drawing
loans in from people and misusing the
money
clearly the ci pumped through that bank
lots of money getting money to its
different operations in in asia and
southeast asia
these people very quickly getting
involved in drug money coming and going
as well but this once again does not
make the case that the cia was funding
its wars
uh with drug money it was just once
again the drug monies moving in the same
world that the war money
is moving and the reason that i'm so
stubborn about this one point
is because one i think i think it's
accurate but also i refuse to let the us
tax dollars off the hook for the wars we
fought
in southeast asia and the millions of
people that were killed you see if we
can say well it was the cia doing it
with drug money then we're
clean the truth is the congress voted on
this money and hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars were
spent to buy those arms to deliver them
and nobody has ever showed us that any
of those arms were paid for with the
drug money we have the congressional
records in a way you know the way the
money was spent the money to buy the
arms and to buy the airplanes
was from u.s tax dollars but what they
did permit this doesn't make them nice
guys god knows but they permitted this
machinery in fact encouraged it to be
used the general gets on a plane each
time with two suitcases of dirty laundry
and and
drops it off and and even going to the
point where when kalki
building a house inside the air base
right beside the airstrip so it would be
so convenient the planes could land and
taxi right up to to the front door and
then you know drive right off the air
force base with the cia
funding the u.s funding the war
funding his air force paying his salary
indirectly buying all the airplanes that
are doing all of this flying and
facilitating his drug operation and
thereby facilitating the whole operation
at the largest scale and in detail the
planes doing the flying flown
by the so-called red-blooded uh uh
u.s pilots but john getting back this
newgan hand bank
one of the things in in a couple of
articles and covered action information
bold defendant some before that and also
in the mother jones they're talking
about one of the functions which they
advertised was laundering in money 20
cents on the dollar
so they would be able to make enormous
profits and
then they also were involved in some of
the illegal arms trade
and not only was the southeast asia but
they also were involved in a drug lord
from
lebanon
so
isn't it possible that some of these
operations in various places of the
world have have actually been financed
that way
i mean there's no way of knowing really
is there
oh the complexities of the flows of
money around the world obviously
masses of money flow loans that bank
tentacles all over the world dealings i
mean you look at the size of the drug
industry the billions of dollars what is
it approaching three billion dollars a
day in arms that are bought and sold
and then the amount of the the drug
trafficking and the volumes yeah the
overlapping and complexity and confusion
everything
that could possibly happen involving
drugs money and arms has happened what
is your feeling then about this christic
institute case that there was a group of
people people like shackley clinus c
cord
and wilson and several others who were
involved in drugs arms deals political
assassinations in vietnam and who
continued in illegal drug and arms and
terrorism assassination operations
throughout the 1970s and then surfaced
again in the iran contra operations the
illegal drug arms operations this of
course is a report that the cristic
institute put out that would
connect cia people other government
officials to international arms and drug
uh rings over a three-decade
period as if there was an intimate
connection between cia and a lot of uh
drug operations were you now skeptical
about when that report you're referring
to which was the original christic
affidavit came out right i and every
other scholar of southeast asia or
activists who had been there challenged
it
as as boulder dash lots of dramatic
errors and false statements and claims
eventually what was it in total or just
some of the dates here and there no bits
and pieces and glimmers of fact
woven together in ways that that that if
that did not come together for example
they claim that theodore shackley
was responsible in 1974 and 75 as chief
of station of saigon
for killing 60 000 people in the phoenix
program
using vang pao drug money to do it with
richard armitage as the bursar the
purpose of the program being to
decapitate the south
because the communists were about to
take over
now
this doesn't add up even at a childish
understanding of southeast asia for one
thing why would you want to decapitate
the south meaning all of the southerners
you'd put in power before the north
takes over make it easier make it easier
for them to take completely communist
regimes absolutely they were going to
decapitate the south you certainly
wouldn't want to do it for them
you wouldn't want to take the
international responsibility for a
bloodbath to make it easier for the
north to take over
the people who did the phoenix killing
and there was a phoenix program and it
was earlier the people who did this
killing in 74 and 75 they were facing a
communist takeover and when you're when
you're looking for justice to be done a
take over by the other side that's not
when you're going to go out and put a
lot of heads on the block and chop them
off you're going to get your head down
and start of you know i'm a very nice
guy and i've always been a little
sympathetic and that's what was
happening then in addition to which
theodore shackley was not in saigon in
74 and 75 he was back in washington in a
very prominent public position
now that kind of error threaded
throughout the entirety of this
affidavit led to its being emphatically
rejected by everybody who knew anything
about southeast asia they hired david
mcmichael
and others and got them in there to
research the thing what kristic did is
they came up with the idea for a lawsuit
under the ricoh thing
and filed a lawsuit and on the basis of
some conversations over dinner just sort
of rough sketches of southeast asia and
they went in as they said at the time
speed writing they wrote that affidavit
one night speed writing from train of
consciousness memory of sort of what
they thought people had said about
southeast asia
and they had a great hodgepodge of
things in there now
the cia had worked with fang powell in
laws
theodore shaklee had been in laos in
fact
and secord had been flying out of
thailand in support of some ci operation
but you see out of context that sounds
very dramatic you know c chord flying in
support the u.s air force was there he
was an air force officer they were
flying
massive operations we were dropping as
many as 700 sorties a day
in laos c-cord was involved in the u.s
air force machine it wasn't you know
shaklee and c cord and laos it was a
gigantic united states southeast asian
policy war right with 600 000 troops and
lots of planes and lots of air force
officers and thousands of cia officers
now vang powell was put into office
uh by the there was a time in laos where
where uh
there was an almost a mad genius in the
way at which every day another warlord
was put in power one ci you'd be off
meeting one guy and work up a big deal
and give him some money and he would
take power and and that afternoon i
would have someone else in power just
because it was all happening so fast we
didn't coordinate bank power was in and
out of office a dozen times as the ci
was juggling people around the common
denominator is that this region was
flowing
drugs the ci had brought in some
agricultural experts to help them
improve the techniques of growing
puppies actually in fact but this did
not
uh add it didn't track what the see what
the christic you know was was claiming
about the area that the affidavit they
wrote it
and then set out to try to prove it if
you want to get a clarification
read their latest document isn't
published yet they're bringing it out in
a little booklet form
in which they cleaned up virtually all
of the horseshit that the first one
included with an occasional blooper in
there that i'm told by people in cristic
danny sheehan just insisted no i'm going
to keep that in there and he was the
boss but they were trying to produce a
document that would stand up to
historical scrutiny david mcmichael was
in the others and and and you know just
occasionally she and said no that stays
and they would argue in fighting no that
states so you read it you can see
compare it with the original document
and the new one and you'll see
the the utter vindication of what we
were saying about the original document
and yet on the other hand there seems to
be from all these various sources a lot
of information some truth to the overall
structure that we're talking about the
cia involved in drugs involved in
assassination and involved in illegal
arms trades
and even for instance in the in the
articles about the negan hand bank
getting back to that it
had
william kobe who was head of the ci one
time he became consultant and then a lot
of the the
primary people in the new guinea bank
were meeting with ted shackley richard c
corbyn thomas clinus uh edmund wilson so
what
uh what what what's what's true and what
isn't i mean we have this all this
information that indicates that what the
christic institute said
there uh is true did they just not
package it correctly they have a bunch
of hasty uh uh
uh bits of misinformation that they put
together
and the things have been thrown out of
court now yeah what's the value of it
what and uh what is the truth john let
me try to formulate what i think your
point is here and that is that it's not
the case or just a small secret team of
people shaklee and clintus and c corp
that were running drugs doing political
assassinations and all these dirty deals
this was just part of normal cia policy
this was just part of u.s foreign policy
that certain operations were carried out
and drugs were tolerated it wasn't that
a small group of people was doing this
it was just part of business as usual is
that the point you're making is against
the
secret team thesis that would seem to
imply that a small renegade faction was
involved in heavy duty
you know drugs political assassinations
arms deals terrorism etc well as you're
saying that this this terrorism and all
these dirty deeds are just simply part
of the infrastructure of the cia but
it's not quite as conspiratorial or
quite as centered in these one group of
people as say the kristic says well is
that a fair and yet you find these same
names popping up all the time this you
know this handful or two of of
significant names popping up only
because christic has been uh suing them
and putting them in the news for from
these other these other articles by
other authors yeah in the last couple of
years since the yeah leslie coburn who
is closely related to the christian
institute well here's a that's
journalist henry cruz yeah oh indeed i
know i know krueger he wrote
or or his cohort uh that who translated
his book the the the the great heroin
coup which which predates the the negan
hands story which jonathan whitney a
friend of mine wrote the book the crimes
of patriots
outlining this thing now
the distortion is this
first the reality that we have confirmed
is that everywhere the ci has run a
major area of covert operations we've
wound up with a major flow of drugs
springing up around it from the infusion
of ci money creating an infrastructure
of contras quote
with airplanes with the facilities with
access to the you know passes to get
through customs and authorities the
french connection
the golden triangle in southeast asia
the golden crescent which we haven't
mentioned
coming out of afghanistan in india where
the the the united states has been
running it's its biggest covert action
of all times and now the medellin the
colombian cocaine connection and central
america lebanese that's that's the
biggest cash crop now is heroin and
and see this this each place the ci has
operated has led to this massive flow of
drugs
and and that we've pretty well
established the ci's
amoral involvement tolerance in the
thing is certainly is that lazy
participation even saying okay no
problem they got you know it's it's
ammoral they're making money that's good
we don't have to ask the congress for
money for him to buy a mercedes he'll
get that on his own uh separately being
content to see it happen
now the thing where christic began with
good cause
to distort the thing is the concept of
the secret team now they borrowed this
from prouty's book which was titled the
secret team in 1972
and what he was calling a secret team
was the same thing that david weiss had
called the invisible government in a
previous book in 1967.
seven
earlier five sixty-five four or five
yeah
the invisible government he was
referring to the people behind the
scenes who were running so much of our
policy in so many parts of the world now
for the purpose of the christic lawsuit
under this racketeering law
trying to win a lawsuit over tony
avergan's injuries in the lapinka
bombing they named 29 people and called
them the secret team
and then they amassed every bit of
information they could and a lot of
disinformation
to make it look like this group of 29
individuals had been responsible for a
chain of evil that dated back 30 years
it was not 29 individuals proud he
didn't mean 29 individuals it was the
invisible government the whole structure
the whole
structure the policies the operations
proudly called it the secret team
weiss called it the invisible government
to win their lawsuit now i don't fault
them for this to win their lawsuit they
personally
personalized it down to 29 men of which
maybe are the major exactly records
secretly klein exactly exactly and i
think it's correctly klein's claims and
now and ed wilson was involved with them
earlier god knows a heavy-duty road to
be big and all these a heavy-duty rogue
now this this the distortion is trying
to boil it down to 29 individuals what
you're doing is you're aggrandizing
theodore shackley right he was one of
probably 700
theodore shackles who've existed in the
40 years the ci's been in business doing
the same sort of things in southeast
asia and france in the middle east
god knows in central america he was just
another one at that level running a
station running a program that god knows
they've killed a lot of people
god knows they've run a lot of wars that
have killed a lot of people they've had
assassination programs going these
things were not funded with vang pao
drug money
they were funded with u.s tax dollars
for 40 years as a matter of us covert
policy
but for which we are absolutely legally
and morally responsible now to win his
lawsuit sheehan had to make a case
against 29 individuals
and and when you get into lawsuits you
distort and twist and focus and play
games
i didn't mind that but where i began to
object was when he began to publish ten
thousand copies of this af david which
was gibberish which he knew was false
but he already published that which he
knew was false because i and jacqueline
sharkey and peter dale scott and daniel
ellsberg and everybody else
who had been involved were telling him
whoa back off rewrite this thing it's
false and they continued publishing it
and these dramatic speeches he was
giving around the nation where he would
put out that information and more
dramatically more embellishing and
enhancing and and making it up forgive
me but making it up as he went along
winging it now this would have the
effect of crossing the line from a
lawsuit
into the public domain into the area
where you and i try to debate the truth
see the one thing that we have going for
us really is the truth as i call it the
intellectual high ground they have the
big bucks the multinational corporations
cbs nbc
the reason people watch this show is
we're trying to get at the truth that's
ignored by the cbs and abc and all of
the major networks
and get out the stories that are true if
we start publishing lies if we start
putting out bs people will listen to us
for a little while and then they'll say
you know and and it quit and we lose the
one thing we've got and that's what
kristic did is they got out and they're
shoveling out a lot of stuff that they
knew was inaccurate saying our lawsuit
justifies the you know the means the end
justifies that there's also a political
issue here we're not only trying to get
the truth out we're trying to change
certain policies that have been in place
for some 40 years now under the american
empire after world war ii on the cristic
institute analysis all you got to do is
get rid of the bad apples you've got to
eradicate this secret team from u.s
government policies and get the bad
individuals out maybe in jail and then
everything's you know cool as a matter
of fact sheehan has said in some cases
quote i'm a patriotic american i believe
in the cia i'm not against the structure
at all
i just want to get the secret team i
think see your point is that it's the
whole operation it's the whole apparatus
of the cia and their policy over 40
years for which is u.s foreign policy
all american season citizens are
responsible and our tax dollars fund
these things right so this is an
important i think difference here
absolutely in terms of politics of the
way to solve these
problems now unfortunately see
christic predictably
has lost this lawsuit
and and there's some basic structural
problems they filed the charges and then
they went to try to dig up the proof for
them and there were some simple problems
involved now
if the lapenca bombing see they were
suing for damages because tony avagin
was injured in a bombing that happened
on the 30th of may 1984.
if that bombing had happened on the 30th
of december they would have had no
problem winning their lawsuit
the iran contra committee report if you
read it it is full of discussion of this
enterprise and it names god knows most
of the defendants in the in the
christian african honey lawsuit and it
maps out where they were getting money
and where they were getting arms how
they were delivering them to central
america including all kinds of things
including c4 plastique
but the problem
was that these activities as they are
documented and provable began after the
boland amendment was passed and it was
passed in september of 84.
and the lepinko bombing was four months
before that
see before that these things weren't
done by private citizens the cia was
doing them with u.s tax dollars as
official congressionally approved policy
absolutely it became a private
enterprise after
the the bull and amendment then the
documentation is massive now it may very
well be that there was this person and
that person involved but but proving it
getting squirts proof getting theodore
shackling a proof of their involvement
it isn't enough to say these people are
evil therefore we should sue them
therefore we should win i mean that's
very nice but it's also very naive and
and and the world isn't that way you
can't just say theodore shackley
presided over some death squad activity
in vietnam
which he did
phoenix program type programs where they
were out there killing people calling it
counter insurgency now but in by my
standards that's not a nice person that
that is a version a form of evil
but when you're going to go into court
or go into the public debate you can't
say because he did that in 1967
or 65 or whenever therefore i can say
anything i want to about him over here
in central america or somewhere else in
the world
it doesn't work that way you lose you
lose your credibility and you don't win
lawsuits you have to prove
that shaklee helped deliver or plot to
deliver the c4 plastique that led to
that bombing
and they were never able to prove any of
that
now
what we're facing
is is a terribly now mind you i would
have loved for them to win that suit in
all of the 40 years the ci has been
blowing up people
they've had protection of national
security and nobody's ever been able to
sue them and no one's really exposed
these operations to public scrutiny such
that network television and all the
media are focusing on these things
before there was the opportunity with
iran contra where for a brief time there
was a focus on some of these operations
and individuals
but it seems well actually to correct
what you i know what you're trying to
say and i agree but
you and i and
lots of us i've been on 60 minutes twice
exposing these things there's been a lot
of exposure walter cronkite
did a story exposing the destabilization
of cuba as did and rather as did bill
moyers and these things were played on
cbs prime time there has been a lot
there's been a lot of exposure over the
years but nothing was tied together yeah
in the way that this christic thesis at
least attempted
to or at least the iran contra was
trying to bring out well the christic
thesis didn't try to tie it together it
tried to to focus it out on to win a
lawsuit on 29 people which was ignoring
the problem is sheen saying i support
the sea i will support this i'm a
patriotic american which would make
if you follow that to the next
conclusion that frank and doug and john
are not because we're you know we're
against the system
not the whole country or at least its
potential but the invisible government
the abuses and perversions of the system
is what we're trying to explore and
educate people about where do things
stand now is this uh
a debacle in miami the christic
institute is that going to
to just blacken all of the information
about the
these these people and the secret
government that we've been talking about
and the iran country drug ring
christic is obviously going to fall back
yes there is a blow struck against the
credibility and the peace movement
however
it's not mortal
even to christic
they have taken a blow there's no
question about that and one putting out
the inaccurate information and then
losing as they've done
nevertheless in the community at large
there is sufficient sophistication
i'm con i'm certain i'm confident that
they're not going to just turn cold on
the thing
they will proceed but if you add that
the discrediting factor of of christic's
mismanagement of this lawsuit if you add
that
to to
dukakis coming in and saying we will run
no more covert operations and the cia
director saying we're getting covered
operations out of the cia
and and the inf agreement it could very
definitely lead to a chilling of energy
in the peace movement while in fact all
of the activities are going full bore
well the more optimistic appraisal is
there might be a turning against
these operations if they're exposed
people know what's at stake here and a
better foreign policy that can be shown
to be in u.s interests can be
formulated and developed and carried
through i mean that would be the
positive effect of oh you're always so
optimistic
what i sincerely hope uh will come out
of this if dukakis does not include
jackson as vice president
is that jackson will pull out and give
us another party they're estimating by
the turn of the century one third of
every citizen of this country will be of
the so-called minorities
if you take that and their interests add
it into their perceptions added into the
the alternative views watchers the npr
listeners
uh we might very well come up with a
party that would be strong enough to
reverse the system the system itself to
make a major impact on the whole
structure of u.s political society it
would involve a new movement a new party
more realistically my appraisal would be
that there's going to be a cover-up on
this whole iran country and a lot of the
dirty dealings of the reagan
administration just won't ever surface
to media consciousness this is what will
be business as usual that dukakis would
not only be managing reaganomics but
he'd be doing damage
control management in terms of u.s
foreign policy all the crimes of the
reagan administration they'll just try
to cover them up and to hold things
in place the only way this could get out
would be if bush starts getting very
close to dukakis in the election and to
make sure that bush doesn't win they
have to nail him on this drug ring and
this will bring all of these stories out
i mean that's a possibility i mean that
could happen
but i read you loud and clear yeah i
think dukakis
will will go to great lengths to avoid
going for the juggler they do not want
to lose the people's credibility they
the democrats they do caucus
to lose the people's trust in the way
they would if they brought out the whole
truth and impeached reagan and jail
george bush
and that's alternative views for this
evening
we'd like to thank our crew our director
brian lynch who also set up the lights
and the audio
our camera people christy bartlett and
scott lassmann
our assistant editor
is anna quad rochi and finally austin
community television
is are the truth going to come out on
this issue is there going to be more
focus on it or is this just going to
disappear like watergate we still don't
know what happened in watergate
no i i think absolutely the iran contra
cover-up of last summer this is the
proper title it's not the iran contra
joint committees of the congress it's
the iran contra cover-up
that they they had a damage control
problem
had they done their duty to this nation
and to the law and to justice
there is not a shadow of a doubt
president reagan would have been
impeached
and george bush would have been
impeached
even now there's a possibility if george
bush doesn't win the presidency that he
could wind up in jail
because if he gets somebody if there's
no ed mesa and they're protecting their
agenda
then you know if you put in a real
attorney general who started encouraging
the attorneys to pursue these things
you bet you're going to wind up with
some prosecutions
many people have asked us to give the
names and addresses of the publications
which we use for news and other source
material
the guardian is a marxist publication
the address is 33 west 17th street new
york new york 1-0-0-1-1
the spotlight is a right-wing populist
publication 300 independence avenue
southeast washington dc
2003
for keeping up with the cia and other
intelligence organizations
it's the covert action information
bulletin po box 50272
washington
zero zero zero dc2000
the national reporter also covers the
cia po box two one two seven nine
washington dc
two zero zero zero nine
in these times is the democratic
socialist publication
1300 west belmont chicago illinois
60657
the nation is a liberal magazine which
has been published for many many decades
72 fifth avenue new york new york one
zero zero one one
utne reader is the reader's digest of
the left
p.o box 1974 marion ohio 43305
nearby